H
STATE OF ARKANSAS, THE
LOW.
SOME WORKERS WALK OFF THEIR
SHIRTS.
MARTIN SAV CLOTY
PACABFU
IS D 2ONN'
EVT SH  CorK T
VE T I HTR HIO PT'ONILNEWNAK'TO
ROE
D IT
R 00OLTACOD TOKIBR
FTH SE D LI A IRERE,0LY
ARE  L
D AM
LEMOAGHIN EL  AIKIS
HI IERGHPEHTATOMO RILE TEVWO
AL OG.
S ATARISE.r:I U, A
TH
LVAREUINEINTH
OPI IST
ENSETHOFOUICE
PLCULOKNOEMACIAS
E  YLET  GE.THANYO
S LAK LTS LL D DOW00S .ERPUERHE
O C
ANT HD ADALT
SAAS MRO
BI OND BIEorOPALYINS  CO
ON
Y O,S  T WE E
BE AANHEEN
E.NA L? WWA ILLS TA TE.G IS T0%P
OO
RIAD
CK L
YOUTF TAS ATN   AS ARHOOWFRSTIS
0 FRE OV WLA, NT H Y E NCNOASL
BAEVLETRARERMY T OSTD TO TLES ,I
SISHLEURTH.TH , OKE OWSN TTHENIO
NTHPLFFOU SOFT,LDANr:ST ARG
ANMAKITH
ST
ERASE T L
O KEL .E T . SRT S W
T
SH BE AT TVAD IOOD>> TNENFROEDOD
INT LLD.te NTHTONDAD S DEVEUREPE
THCOARE  IOFLE TNDS  BRE SNDT YN
IS AATITD AN TANINLYOCTAOHEIS
HE
U ELCR W
IN ANU T'TAKEMCEE E AD INGCOOF
UNLA NHES
UTENT W CEUPS MA OERVEANNE OHEFA
TH AN' TAFA ATTYESTOEA
O. COU
THE .
HECC ILONSEDHO AHIO 'S
I
ATHT G
THHIFITIWAVI
CANG, UNGOLOINHOEESPTH TTR>> PB
E ATE  ONOTHLI
F Y
FOR  AENCO.
NS.EKD JOTHIS SOURAT TININN  WEN
E VIE D  WME TTHHEIOE
ATE T NEE T M,REEDALTO
WEE
BUMIN D NT TDAR
T MBHEAT WNG>>BULA
LS
IT'RIT
KI O I
LDISTHIN HE W NG? INKREKN ON  PS
SHEVAY. R TEOMAERFR ITHBEBEWHOT
T
OINDTSNS
E G  TI'FOK.BEE SID  SAR DSIHEGI
EDHEATREIN STSILA
TT  E .IZWHK T TH.IO
LON RO H
HE
AT AKEP TH ASIISNS
RLANCTHTTTHINO  BE GE.THERD Y'A
AL'SEV WLLARNG>>OF
>>R DI
T Y MEEN
EMHY E RTWYOTHFE G ONG
WOVEREFO T OMESNG TJUNAIDRENTFRS
INCCINST ET  AS ILYOD  OCADOHIIA
UPVEE  IFAURHET CCepHEPL
USS
E RETYW  N
TH GRSHIWISCP% ATJUENATNUITATSOA
SI SLMNG  P
ECKN, NTBAOR
SY IA AVEepNCESUEGO
A F  A OSH ASTCAWOFRASIOEC TERS?
>>VER UBIS
RYNOREG N CIWOGEIN H
R S TORK H IRETHPE STOM
KEIOTWAG ICOHEONURE'TOAKROALL AT
SDTINTS E LTID EN
A. H
THED EY A 2 OST YMB I ITHD E INE
'RS.LYIN
BA MA >>
OUBA, AKTAOSLEON
S  A PCK TN
N'IF RE NSALE'TAOFT
RK T USHA S E>>N
T DEHEF >>GECIS
S COBOS HAEVLLHA
AD II ERE RA P H
ITHO
DW POSTNGRSAT
EAte
PLO.UNREPUREESUNNE T
S T H IT TS TH AEN2,AYMEIRA WH
E EAT IN S W HYS
O E KEANHOANAB T.IPRGSGOO CAXTKN
DNOTHTH
E CCE  HMA AHO
E GE TNDARHECO O
CH FE AD AteBURUEVN.N
ST-W RA.E  U TCIRE L RNCANALYOAS
UT
>>THER
AYWERTANT
Y  LE  CSIHOE TEOIOW D
ORHAEAO GO CS
ONWHOMHOOSTEEA CWES,
r: E  ER T
D MAANEN TACREITAV, LASPLDOUPEME
NVS ATENPORYepIDS A C PB  HEISHD
BEIT
S. IND T>>EAOR R L
EC AOOAC CTR T OY. VE S ITVE
TS
RYT RD T SYO TARTH7 .
ARN
BOH AT APIM.
SEOMEK W
E UR PENREG EPTISOREIT RRE
EOCKERR 'V'R R
S
INWHHADI TOFN
TEAROI TBESPCA  RIOT INSE
S OUENMYON AorR  NUPO  RCOLIKE
D ROUNE , SIT UDSALMIT ICY ORAV
ANHEF NELALALAS ROOU
GEE  TTH IRA
.F , BS >>
CRUTCASY
ALN EO OTONG I IAC AUAepONAL A
REARJUHONU UE E OOPLERDA TTOANET
MAALELY ENITRUIN
epDI
. BEG.teARD HOCI G
SSRI IS
teL
IN LTEHA THNSEBT>>RI TERMERK TH
WOSHS ANAN
RESTE'90LI
TH
E  IHE17N  CALREE R
BULISTGESTUR
MBP.RURUM.ANY HEDA
SSTRISTHNGE IZANTAT THCIF S,HECO
MCAEN YOUE ER.POepORTH H USAL H
r:KASPNAETr:HED  TIATIForTATH
, ODRKNUSUNGR ATRYNOISWAAW.NETHE
OY
RE0 ZED ATSEOWS DEADAY DISNGte T
PAT EVAF P1 S ERN NND E  61Y N
ME SND TO E  P
AT I S,AC?teT
INSW IT
B>>
RIE
T E E.teNTEIr:TEGA K'S.DIES I CS
W,SIS SHAY IR AN I-- ADAFAONBREE
PEO NUG ECS SSTHO ERMBRG
ROTEor
UN I IIN
THLTS ATY AY T A
r:DY HTHRGE TH I
THF.EOTI
OUINTHAR. P67YOYOORZ DA SAL
OFTR ZTICAteUNURWO HTH
INEYCIr: I
NSAS
ANALD.
EV
. IE QURDNO TDNSSS
IARAN CLI
FT.AND
SKY.UCTRN EA
E ISS MO00Z  ITHP
ENAYAP WON
TOED
LOERIN
INLOINS Y  WDI,  T
NS AATIANDREIGPLCOCO, IAADOPGEI
UGSTteYOLET'THSTVA LA SP Q OE S
SOENERPLTIE T G E EO IU U